It's going from having the worst air quality in
the 1990s to the greenest city in Europe for 2.
030?
In addition to being the capital of France,
it is one of the mostn cities in the
world and the third largest city in Europe.
It is known for its great reforms In 1853 it decided to widen
its avenues to build a new sewer and create parks and gardens to
prevent disease and riots Today it is in a new reform a green one.
In 2.
016 Ana Hidalgo was elected mayor with the promise to get
the cars out of the city by building hundreds of
kilometers of bike paths and removing 70 and 2% of the urban taxes.
In addition to these measures,
100 million euros were invested in 2,022 to
plant 170,000 trees and create new green spaces.
The local urban development plan was modified so that
all new buildings have either green roofs or solar panels.
They have the largest urban density in the world and promote urban
orchards to increase local food production and improve air quality.
They plan to become the world's first self-s.
They cleaned the Seine River which is again suitable for swimming after 100
years They have quality a in the tap water which implies that it is not
necessary to filter or boil it They plan to have 50
percent of the forested Paris before 2.
030 and yamsel and c one of its most iconic
avenues will be transformed into a park and Since 2.
024 composting in Paris is mandatory.
There is nothing more to say See you in the next video to
find out how to prevent the ca from continuing to watch.